jours on a eu l'idée qu'ont les gens
tournage ya moins de trois mois
c'est parti pour trois semaines très
intenses et disais merde quand est ce
qu'on fait de perdre des membres de
l'équipe ce week end à corps
et quand on était dans des conditions
extrêmes une crise d'angoissé longtemps
qu'on n'a pas dormi on a fait un film
aux conditions extrêmes des cracks
appels et les pc des manques carnoux 3
vais écrire un long métrage
j'avais dit
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
juste après jour de nos mères on était
très fatigué et surtout rares cas et
donner encore plus que nous on n'a pas
forcément continuer la fin de saison
qu'on avait prévu sur les quatre parce
qu'on était assez fier de ce qu'on avait
fait on sait bien c'est bien quand même
de finir l'année sur eux sur une longue
vidéo comme ça on est ressortis de la
épuisé
super content dit ce qu'on avait à faire
des faits la projection etc et les gens
beaucoup aimé le film sketch m'a
beaucoup mieux marché qu'on espérait on
n'avait pas envie de directement faire
une saison 3 sur le même
même processus quand on s'est dit bon
peut-être pas s'amuser autant sur la
saison 3 donc autant faire une petite
pause avec leur à fond on a travaillé
ensemble sur une série et du coup on
s'est vu un peu plus et un soir on était
côte mon livre dans un bar et ont parlé
cinéma en design et pour une énième fois
on se disait qu'on avait envie de faire
des longs métrages
on se disait merde quand est-ce qu'on
fait du style avec un jean
on en rêve depuis qu'on a 12 ans quand
est-ce qu'on pourra en faire la pression
d'avoir des révélations ce soir là on
s'est dit oui il n'ya pas pensé plus tôt
pourquoi on n'a pas eu lieu
c'est d'avoir le courage de chanter et
danser la veille le lendemain en fait
venir prochaine du procès envers les
textos on a parlé à vincent les gars
sont venus vers moi en disant ah on
aimerait bien faire refaire du jury 4
mais en plus gros seins comme des
fantômes de berne est peut-être plus
long si tu es chaud moi j'ai dit non
mais parce que ça me paraissait
complètement en phase avec la vie n'a
pas hésité longtemps
il a pas hésité longtemps il ya dirais
ok il a juste dit si je me suis là je
dis ouais il faut juste la bonne
histoire
il faut juste le bon truc ne faisons pas
un film pour faire un film
retrouvons ensemble tous les trois une
idée qui nous plaît le fait de se poser
tous les trois derrière une table les
idéaux s'user bareback porter six men en
mémoire vidéo
grégoire
fortis
6cette pitch de films un peu différent
en tête qui nous plaisait déjà un petit
peu on s'est dit là déjà le projet
commencé à vivre en fait on commence à
se dire ok là on a envie de faire un
film est vraiment présente on n'a pas
encore on sait pas encore laquelle de
ces idées on va faire mais on a envie
d'en faire un donc du coup on s'est dit
qu'on allait contacter julie coudry qui
donc qui est devenu du coup la
directrice de production sur ce problème
quand je travaillais sur la prépa de
badass de ma famille car les taux et ils
m'ont expliqué qu'ils avaient envie de
faire un film et qui voulait le faire
avec moi j'ai réfléchi à peu près 4
secondes et et j'aurais répondu tout de
suite que oui j'étais partante on a
commencé à réfléchir à des trucs
ensemble notamment financement et l'idée
en gros c'était arrivé dans le bureau
d'à derrière le bestiaire dans le
producteur de gaulle des moustaches avec
un projet entre guillemets quasiment
clés en main moi je pensais qu'ils
avaient proposé de faire une ou deux
vidéos un truc comme ça et ils ont dit
voilà on note prolait ça serait plutôt
de faire une seule vidéo très longue
un film oger petit qui au départ sur le
parce que je me suis demandé comment il
allait comment y voyez le financement le
budget etc
aujourd'hui quand on fait un programme
audiovisuel en général
le financement est assez calibre et nous
notre problème c'est que on voulait
faire un film sur internet gratuit pour
le consommateur c'est ça n'existe pas il
fallait réfléchir à des moyens
alternatifs de financement
voilà financé à 80% par le placement de
produits on a également complété avec
une petite sortie en salle qui est assez
peu d'argent et le but du jeu là c'est
d'arriver à l'équilibré financier
on n'espérait pas gagner de l'argent on
en espérait ou ne pas trop en perdre en
fait de leur démarche hier à côté on va
faire un signe pour notre public pour
notre génération avec les moyens du bord
on se débrouille en mettant de l'huile
de coude pour remplacer l'absence de
financement c'est exactement le genre de
projet que j'avais envie de faire en
tant que producteur le plus fou c'est
qu'adrien la bassetière à 10 go et on
avait un micro pitch quoi vraiment de à
et si les gens échangent et de corps
c'est un peu ça si j'aurai deux corps un
peu tout le temps julie nous avait dit
il faut qu'il ait un nom ce projet vont
pas appeler le projet de vouloir faire
un film que ça dans juste pour les mails
pour dire ça parle de ça et du coup ces
divas appelons le chantal qu'on voulait
pas se stresser pour qu'on voulait pas
dire on va sur le film se diront bois
sur chantal ça va s'appeler paulo
c'était notre projet secret mais c'était
pas non plus n'avait pas pour projet
d'envoyer un missile sur un pays donc
c'était pas trop trop grave
avant que ça s'appelle chantal le
premier nom de code que j'ai proposée
s'étaient droit dans le mur
on a plein d'idées dm donc des droits
dans leurs concerts imposer un
calendrier qui était très serré
volontairement parce que on le faisait
avec peu d'argent c'est un projet
ambitieux mais on s'est dit faisons le
duc ou spontanément que c'était arc on a
peu de temps il faut trouver vite une
idée vite une idée pas cher invite un
sketch qui coûte 100 euros
donc là c'est un peu pareil on s'est dit
bon bah continuons sur la même lignée
que les saison 1 saison 2 fixons nous
nous mêmes une commande en fait j'ai
bien ça parlera de quoi et c'est
précisément voire six mois on saura
faire des transferts corporelle c'est le
mot créé mon record c'est quoi un titre
on était en mars à l'époque et on s'est
dit au caire des lois qui sortent en
septembre donc ça nous laisse trois mois
d'écriture trois semaines de tournage de
mois de montage pour des créatifs c'est
une bonne chose de se succéder des
courses et permet de mobiliser leur
énergie
sur un moment précis ceci dit c'est la
pire des contraintes en fait donc et a
priori il n'y avait aucune raison de le
faire donc
après moi je respecte leur envie de
faire les choses comme ça mais j'aurais
pu prendre six mois de plus à mon avis
on essayait vraiment de partir sur trois
personnages qui avait pris 3 à 3
enveloppes différentes s'énerver ce
serait cool ou pillées en fait pour y
voir des vieux puis on pourrait avoir
n'importe quel âge n'importe quelle
couleur
c'était ce que permettait notre concept
d' intéressant c'était normal une petite
famille en fait tous les trois et ça ça
nous plaisait beaucoup on savait qu'on
peut aller traiter d'un coup parce qu'on
faisait pas trop cool avec cette idée
[__] j'ai vraiment on peut jouer un
couple quoi un le couple hétéro mais
dans les cordes de domec et s'il y avait
un mec avec barbu en costard qui pleure
un côté tu as et en fait il dit j'ai
perdu ma maman etc
ça nous a fait rire de se dire t'as un
mec de 30 ans pleure comme un bébé est
en fait c'est un bébé à l'intérieur du
titre demandent à le faire à vos quêtes
suricates du futur les seniors semblent
à quoi ils essaient plutôt un cheminot
vous êtes plutôt matrix où on en est en
un mot la mort ces deux mots morlaàs
qu'ils allaient prévu du script est loin
de chez vous sur les 4-10 gens
intelligents frais une histoire simple
déjanté j'en mettrais des gens dans une
cabane avec un monstre et voilà c'est
sûr il reste dans la cabane pendant tout
le film et ils survivent mais nous on
n'est pas intelligent et de cours se dit
viens on fait des trucs avec des sables
pas parce que c'est là que vladimir
rodionov le directeur artistique est
vraiment nous a vraiment aidés comme
parce que s'il était là pour nous aider
à une hyper efficace l'écriture c'est
compliqué parce qu'il y avait très peu
de temps pour le faire il fallait aller
vite
elle est très efficace un film ou mieux
ces trois ces mois de travail avait fait
deux écritures là il y avait deux mois
moi je dis je le disais bon oui oui on
va tenter
et puis on va repousser jusqu'à gravera
tu retourneras en septembre c'était bien
et n'ont obtenu il voulait tenir
absolument attendait en juin lors
desquelles est peut-être une ou deux
semaines par rapport au planning
original c'était super tendu vers
l'écriture
sans lui on n'aurait pas pu écrire un
film du tout parce qu'il est assez
strict sur sa méthode d'écriture sur
comment traiter une idée première étape
définir les règles de l'univers on sait
que les retouches et on peut changer de
changer de damas rejette corps il ya une
multiplication et la division et la
possession ces mots assez compliqué
toutes ces questions là ça a mis du
temps déjà le réseau n'était pas clair
et du coup tu peux commencer à bâtir
l'histoire mais tentons univers et passe
à se bâtir ensemble en fait qu on serait
toujours l'histoire les personnages et
l'univers du temps on a essayé de faire
un pli sur la toujours pas parce que
notre idée elle est tellement alambiqué
tellement chelou qui font qu'on voulait
la résumer au plus simple voire
l'expliqué un enfant de 8 ans et c'est
une grand mère de 77 ans et que les deux
comprennent vraiment de ce christ de
quoi il s'agit on a des esquisses de
personnages faire une esquisse de
ludivine donc il appellera pas ludivine
veille qu'elle est l'héroïne qui est en
train de se dessiner
on a la forme on a les balles on a le
choix de corps on n'a qu'à changer le
coeur au dalo nabeul qui se détache de
mon port qui est le point de départ je
pense comme on se disait du truc c est
qui permet tous les lots de pouvoir
briller mais je pense que ce qu'il nous
manque complètement c'est une intrigue
en fait c'est une menace et à certains
tricks à implique d'avoir un nom
ni ce qu'elle est là forces antagonistes
et un des défauts j'ai passé dans ma vie
que je le dise mais un des défauts du
fantôme de merde c'est que l'antagonisme
c'est pas du tout claires et des steak
and me faire faire mieux l'espace il
nous a dit très vite c'est cool c'est
que le c'est cool mais ils ont des
enjeux ils ont des problématiques qui
les personnages ont des choses à régler
mais vous avez un l'espèce de méchant
qui est quand même pas très développée
où on comprend pas ses motivations et il
ya pas mal de petits gars de la route on
arrête deux mois devant nous pour faire
un séquencier et aurait pas de souci
le souci c'est le cycle c'est que là on
n'a pas assez de moi on a une oreille
car il manque une semaine à la
résistance contre contre un grand
méchant il ya bien il manque encore
clairement identifier la menace là pour
l'instant cette histoire là le manque
totalement de temps je suis arrêté car
ces questions là aujourd'hui c'est là
pas de souci pour ce cas-ci faiblard si
justes mais qu'au guidon qui l'évoqué
barge défi c'était la structure en fait
c'est que raconter une histoire sur plus
d'une heure tu peut ennuyer les gens
tu peux raconter tout ce n'est pas
cohérent on s'est vraiment compliqué la
tâche à notre premier truc avec leurs
mille personnages avec 1000 arc et mille
trucs a justifié mme nahles
mais leur partage ici qu'ils empêchent
d'agir en fait un joueur qui change les
gens qui aiment les chiens dalé lary
réussite fuit la scène en fait ce genre
c'est juste la menace monte doucement
vraiment très de son pour arriver à ce
point culminant alors vous êtes agressé
pas forte
t'as pas de danger et a pas de menace a
pas d'urgence des personnages végète
âgées vivent leur vie ils ont leurs
critiques mais il n'y a pas d'obstacles
très fort et coûteux obstacles puis
traduit simple moi j'ai pas assister au
tournage je m'étais la population du
montage
j'ai trouvé que les cénacles
antagonistes était super forme et c'est
avec lille aurait dit super corps
élastique et ça on la fonction dans
trois semaines
ouais et politiques troisième but à
l'autre et là on est dans la période où
tous à oullins premier coup on a repris
un peu du poil de la bête on est sûr
définissent et concise normalement la
vie 8,9 c'est la bnf sur vingt pages et
tu vois ça c'est une séquence est donc
on décrit tout ce qui s'y passe tous les
enjeux de quoi parle à cela la situation
et où elle arrive en lots trop prend sa
chance derrière de plus les dialogues
donc en fait donc quoi tu fais x x 4 à
peu près donc ça va faire deux pages si
ça fait déjà et ce quasiment 20 pages et
c'est quasiment la durée le nombre de
pages que vous et le fantôme de merde
avec le fantôme de mer nous a permis de
nous dire c'est possible de faire un
truc avec une équipe restreinte qui
était à l'époque
clément morin des rémillard go donc sont
les images
alors là c'est une petite réunion a peur
un peu qu'il en change tout mais c'est
la réunion déjà avec aimants et clinique
qui vont être les deux personnes qui
vont prendre sa possible du coup on va
essayer leur expliquer ce que lorsqu'on
a concocté et quel point c'est chelou et
est dur à faire mais enfin vous
compliqué à faire on fait ça en live
avec vincent tir elle va sentir l de new
york nyse
[Musique]
on a visité un appart aussi wii qui est
pas mal du tout qui est juste à côté de
juste à côté de l'itie le golem sache
qui a déjà un chat on a vu tout seul en
fait à part un peu bobo arty mais non la
production d'orge
si on choisit cet appart on n'est pas un
must have pour tous problèmes de matos
la ch26 comédiens peut-être aussi sur la
porte je suis pas d'être des grands
renforts de laisser des salaires et
coûts qui fait qu' on ne sait pas encore
pour l'instant et on sait tout mais je
pense que beaucoup de questions pour les
comédiens rien été fixé en fait même les
rôles de l'île y ait de ben ils sont
interprétés par marsu lacroix yoneda ils
ont été ça s'est décidé d'être à deux
semaines du tournage
quelque chose comme ça voulait mettre
tous les potes d'internet dans le film
mais on voulait mettre aussi des gens
qui viennent d'univers en fait pour faut
pas que ce soit un film 100 % le lol lol
de mov'it eu à internet 2.0
un film dont on connaît plein de gens
des françaises en tête parce qu'on les
adore on avait beaucoup ce qu'ils
faisaient
pour les franglaises c'est pv nova qu'on
connaît bien qu'ils nous avaient invités
chacun aux deux côtés julien
rafle mois à voir le spectacle qui était
génial
[Musique]
brest
j'avais joué qu'une seule fois avec eux
j'ai fait une petite apparition en robin
en super-héros the hangover
mais ça a été déjà très très coup pareil
une vidéo et plein de monde et juste
fait un gros fan de leur travail c'est
franchement le collectif que je préfère
sur internet ils m'ont appelé et m'ont
dit écoute on a donc ce projet qui est
un peu qui est un peu différent on a
pensé un rôle pour toi donc moi j'avais
déjà un rôle à titre et ils m'ont
demandé le contact de plusieurs
comédiens donc il ya trois autres
anglais ce qu'on déroule le transforme
et rage et de douleur n'a fait des
passes et des petits et s'est assis
ouais ça si six comédiens des problèmes
11 et tarifs touche où tous incroyable
donc c'était cool c'est la première fois
qu'on faisait surtout passer des
castings c'était bizarre pour nous on a
pris quelques scènes clés qu'on avait
déjà un peu écrite on avait des v1 et on
les a fait jouer par différentes
combinaisons de comédien quand on avait
dit qu'on n'allait pas dit que c'était
des nausées dacca qui rit je vais
prendre les prochains vomi promis qu'on
a tous les trois hull coup de coeur pour
johnny aimart su on voyait vraiment
couple comme ça quand un bus où nous a
épatés sur tous les rôles quentin depuis
le début on l'aimé beaucoup et on le
sentait bien en milo crois que tous les
dissocier c'est les gens à qui on a
proposé en premier en fait le casting
idéal de dissocier c'est celui qui à
l'image que ça soit les copains du web
grave et qu'il en avait plus ou moins
tourner tous
parce que c'est tellement des conditions
de tournage extrêmement fait qu'on est
obligé de tourner entre potes comme un
ver se prendre votre temps le fort bien
commun tout s'arrêterait caucus scénario
mettre la foule vous me l'étais de
recréer les scènes de s'approprier le
dialogue en interne et en fait on a
écrit vraiment la version est
informative pour fixer les visages sacha
sacha guen sont désistés parrainée par
monsieur monsieur chantal lérus h à la
salle moussa saïb guen qui a laissé des
cours devient de bien lire et 9 juin à
lévis mais reçues on aliot ni qui nous
fait ben gourion de milo qui est fait
parfois on allie mots sont associés à
exister surtout pas dire si avec tout ce
que vous prenez pas pendant la lecture
que ce soit ça casse à sa texture
cellules qui motive un peu compliqué
tout le monde parte avec le même clou
dans la tête et qu'on a tous compris la
même chose l attention qu il ya encore
ses marques et dans le corps de sa dette
à vous de faire les lapix il est prévu
un stage pour moi je sais pas faire
[Musique]
surikate résume-t-il scénario très vite
il 03 06 15 matin j'en vois deux nuits
vide long couloir une boîte de nuit
ville une louche passe une durée de 7
ans tendrement le ton monte
quelqu'un crie bien c'est toujours en
temps de guerre comme des dératés
passage plein de points chantal sérieux
stupide avant d'être en fait on devrait
tous des cannibales est obligé d'ouvrir
la bouche pont pasteur d'action
[Musique]
je fais face à la grippe à quillan
on s'échauffe et va jouer à chat qu'on
pose pas certaines scènes comme j'ai pas
à 4,5 personnage dans le film once est
donc forcément il ya un moment où tu es
perdu pour la production je me suis
entouré de ma petite soeur elodie on
s'amusait à prendre tout un mur de
golden et essaie de faire un plan de
travail le plus intelligente possible en
fonction des comédiens des décors et
d'autres contraintes qu'on pouvait avoir
là en gros la dernière semaine talent
avec quatre jours là est 1,5 mg alors
parce qu'on a beaucoup beaucoup de
séquences m trois semaines très intenses
vincent et julien avait repéré déjà la
machine du moulin rouge dans laquelle
ils voulaient tourner et malheureusement
la boîte de nuit était en travaux on
s'en est rendu compte au repérage et
pourtant avant le tournage cette partie
là elle veut dire
l'idéal pour nous aurait été d'avoir eu
tort d'un peu de liberté de mouvement du
combat paraît un tournage a light pour
ça il n'a pas le temps de deux
soulac ça c'est quand même une celle qui
vit donc vous auriez jamais eu une
liberté totale tout le temps est
toujours une utilisation de la salle si
vous avez vraiment besoin d'un site d'un
silence dans la salle ça veut dire qu'on
doit arrêter toutes nos activités
pendant une semaine ça c est ce week-end
tête c'est ça le truc le plus
envisageable ça la nuit mais j'pense que
penses-tu de nuit ça nous donc le peuple
un pouvoir celui des personnes à
l'offrir quand tu fais sa survie du 22h
à 8h 10h du mat
le bateau n'est 100% légal est quoi ce
qui est une demande aux gens de dormir
la journée de de faire leur mue la
journée et tout ce que tu en as placard
on passe des cas l'équipe
ce qui va ce visage et c'est pour être
les quatre nuits 4 mai de nuit on sera
peut-être on en fera chier moins deux
personnes et et on pourra peut-être plus
tout entier ça découle une boîte de nuit
vide c'est nickel on peut tourner deux
jours reste étant détenu
on a essayé de rajouter des étapes qui
était important pour trois projets de
cette envergure a fait quelques petites
répétition de scènes clés vraiment une
après-midi ou deux avec pareille des
comédiens important
et une après-midi tout juste né seyaj
costumes moi je suis content on joue
déjà aujourd'hui une journée
[Musique]
tu penses que je vais je vais garder ce
rush et on les met direct donc anticiper
un petit peu on s'est dit qu'on n'aura
pas de maquilleuses en aura pas de
costumière et d'accessoiristes du coup
on leur a demandé de nous préparer plein
de choses on fume dans les costumes et
donc on s'habillait nous mêmes par
exemple sur le tournage la vie manière
dont ça se trouve le style de magali
style de malades le plein de petits
trucs à essayer ou le métrage avait si
tu veux mais je vais en mettra pas parce
qu'on ne veut pas la féminiser trop on
sait que ces dérives et il est inscrit
hier quat'sous qui veut dire qu'en
japonais sur icap cédera pas quoi déçu
ah c'est une vraie rappaz tissus et et
tous s'accordent ils à avoir mal
moi j'ai fait une crise d'angoissé la
veille la veille je n'allais pas bien
eux
j'étais tout seul chez moi et ce gros
tonnage qui m'attendait c'était la cne
quoi j'ai pris ma récréation un grand
coup et je vais c'est parti pour trois
semaines faut être à fond faut tenir
donc se dire ah ça va être crevant mais
on connaît on a déjà fait on va y
arriver
moi je me souviens que c'était plus le
premier actions étaient un peu bizarres
quoi c'était 2-2 csa ya quoi c'est le ça
tourne moteur on est sûr vraiment y
aller en fait les frais la nouveauté là
sur ce tournage c'est le rhône est un
outil pour tous lui nettement ses
mouvements c'est vachement bien il
compte faire des plans des blancs
séquence ou presque
beaucoup de long où la caméra pour
demain gouanou juillet maussade a un
côté plus cinéma sympathique je penserai
light manière théorique art chinois mais
monsieur laissez moi entrer sur le toit
mais c'était super cool à faire ta
première fois que avec vous neuf avec
julien joue mon mec alors mettre sa voix
cassée
c'est tout
on se voit dans le miroir et quand on
s'apprête à crier on n'avait pas envie
de vraiment de crier on voulait plus
criant c'est beaucoup on est tous pas la
tête on a juste fait la criée genre de
seconde
en fait c'est de manière c'est le poulet
qui crient à notre place la partie
n'était pas si grand que ça donc on
devait tout bougeait à chaque fois en
gros quand vous voyez dans le film que
l'on tombe dans le salon c'est que dans
la chambre c'est le bordel clairement il
fallait au moins une pièce voire
d'autres bus c'est en effet on dormait
au lieu des flight case il y avait des
la caméra là dedans mais là donc ici
c'est la pièce où on raphaël des cracks
a dormi cette nuit et où je veux en rien
avec lui ce soir
voilà et si on vit en permanence sur le
lieu du tournage
c'est à dire si on dort dans les câbles
et les objectifs de caméras quand on se
réveille le matin en dix minutes on est
prêts tac tac puis voilà puis on peut
tourner quoi horrible tous les bateaux
tous les matins
[Musique]
planches de bd on sert dans ta comics et
on s'apprête à colorier
[Musique]
on
les contours d'un article totalement
effrayé et
on a un peu de prises par leurs plans
confiance mutuellement tourner un peu
sous pression mais on a beaucoup de
choses à rentrer par jour voilà qu on
flippe à 7,11 mal à lui peut être
séparée ça fait partie et ça fait partie
du deal fait de ce genre de tournage
c'est que tu tombe amoureux d'une scène
et tu en rêves pendant des mois et des
mois
tu l'as tant que de la tournée un jour
est un jour de la montée et et quand ça
arrive ça arrive entre 10h et 10h30 du
matin
enfin ça arrive tu n'as pas ta qu'une
demi-heure pour la tournée alors que tu
avais rêvé de cette scène de ouf action
photo j tout s est favorite il est calme
en une matinée
tiens à ce que j'avais à septembre bien
les faire et au final va arriver au
montage
quand tu t'aperçois que ça marche votre
super content de son lamentable zhaoxu
m'énerve c'est moi c'est que je n'avais
pas pris conscience qu'ils étaient 13h30
donc on a perdu une demi heure sur leurs
pas nous avons là le temps donc on fait
ça bien pour le temps pensé mais je sais
qu'on finira très bien lui sa patrie
mais dans soit par na le nombre disent
qu'on aura plus aucun souci mais par
contre je me suis supporter après c'est
la première fois qu'on sort de cet
appartement en jour
et bien sortir mais oui on est on
commence vraiment à monter les doses de
caféine emploie six mois ça va
le pire vraiment là il s'agit des cracks
qui met en scène qui vous dira vraiment
bon mais ça doit être un exemple fin de
semaine c'était un petit peu bouffé
d'oxygène parce qu'on travaille avec
d'autres comédiens fait et donc kyan et
navo ça nous semblait être une un beau
clin d'oeil à fantômes de bien et ça
nous fait tout le temps marrer de voir
obtient un personnage vraiment à côté
qui est comme un peu un spectateur qui
seraient projetés comme ça dans le film
qu'est ce que c'est que ce monde de
tarak les gros janis est en fait oui
voila quoi choquer en place s'élance et
me dit on et que les mâles concept de la
team770 katsuya okada grosse personnage
de tuffé kian qui était dans le monde de
merde subie à chaque fois les trucs
chelous qui arrivent dans nos scénarios
quoi tu vas vu qu'on est très large
après l'impact sévère ils forment un
pacte de toute dernière face aux vielles
qui s'est un peu défroqué tu viens pas
vraiment la garde à toi tu es dans moi
moi je suis dans toi là
annick la télé depuis l'écriture en gros
on a vraiment vu ça comme notre zone
sketch quoi c'est le sait la oumma
s'amusait beaucoup plus où ça à partir
plus dans la parodie
c'était l'occasion d'éviter ce qu'on
aime bien qu'ils nous font rire aussi
mais les potes avaient pensé à vous
engager deux hommes ont valu en cuisine
un toc toc show équipe de type à mon
poste
jamais jamais
côté
l'ensemble
fleck et magali regarder une émission à
la compagnie semble type télétubbies et
très tôt en fait c'était c'était le
palmashow qu'on avait en tête pour faire
ce à quoi jamais froid une émission de
télé pour enfants sera jamais le front
ça pas dans leurs aspirations en tout
cas nous aider mais nous on aimerait
contrôler voire dans là dedans donc
vient dans notre télé dans notre télé
fictive à nous ils sont dans une
émission pour enfants texte ou coupées
merci beaucoup les mecs la deuxième
semaine c'est plein de décors différents
d'extérieur et avec plein de points
chaque jour était différente on a un
truc différent dans un lieu différent et
le soir fallait rentrer chez soi dormir
mais là ce qui était trop bien cette
semaine là c'est que je viens vincent et
moi on tournait en tant que comédien que
en fin de semaine la sienne sur le toit
du grand air
à commencer par le hangar c'était cool
parce qu'on avait toute une journée pour
faire pas beau pas tant de choses que ça
donc on a pu bien les faire tu as et on
a pu faire avec le renard justement en
plan séquence donc se balader parmi les
gens on a pu faire des beaux plans en
fait d'être contré de foot
en fait on essaie de faire croire qu'on
a mille figurants alors qu'on en a deux
classes et les faux séquence
l'immolation par le feu très bas dans ce
4ème à nantes alors que juste avant fait
des vagues sur le prout la sec avec des
gens ce bull compte mettre en place
devant finir sur toi je t'ai le bidon et
la personne à côté de toi qui pourrait
être laurent va te faire juste faire
comme ça il va être le fils est comme ça
cette personne je vous dis à rémy a car
je viens on va faire une répète une
répétition de notre histoire
peut passer un genre tête à l'ancienne
avant on passe devant que sa chorale
attendait que très peu de fois
est ce que c'est que la case famille et
n'a qu'un caleçon
et du coup il va vous emmener devrait
surtout un peu de façon aléatoire est
assez basse c'est un plan séquence ou
d'un marché entre des gens à l'envers ne
pas leur rentrer dedans c'est pas su non
plus c'est que moi je tiens ça me rase
en même temps il a une petite
télécommande et du coup je pense cadrés
et faire les clowns qui comparaissent de
cinq conséquence un peu son on savait
que il y avait la conclusion de
l'histoire et on se rendait compte avec
le personnage d'adrien meyniel que oui
mine de rien ça fait quand même une
heure de film qui se baladent en slip et
que sa part fait le prix normal pour
tout le monde non gérés ont su le faire
gaffe à deux choses c'est la dernière
goutte quand l'officier et des
mouvements trop tu bouges une jambe
ça soulève de le côté c'est l'exposition
testiculaire c'est un pari super risqué
pour nous de se dire les grands aveux
des héros à la fin du film vont pas se
faire à travers nos corps en fait alors
que ces décors que tu as suivi tout le
long du film
est ce que va faire lucien d'apprendre
l'impact aussi d'affaires tête à gauche
est à droite et va dire lire votre butin
vous derrière sur la même chose que lui
[Musique]
vous savez déjà qu'on mélange diallo des
séquences avec une autre se passe maman
suis-je en a écrit vite au coeur des
forêts crée des répliques de four
informative tout le barda ya des flèches
matin voilà vous prélasser à ce qui se
profile c'est un échange du dialogue
entre deux personnes qu'on met
concrètement entre 6 super 5 en cours il
a déboulé sur le tournage avec un
dialogue qui me plaisait qu'à moitié
on savait que l'on travaillerait
globalement je crois qu'on a fait des
assez bonne modifications et on a la
plupart du temps je pense améliorer les
scènes ont l'air travaillant sur place
oui je crois je crois que ça va
[Musique]
compliqué comprenne qui est des
commandes a fixé un code de champ contre
champ où la gauche ban qui parle de
ménard maire de droite cds nikki pas
bête
ouais bon c'est comme ça
des chevaux
[Musique]
tourné avec baptiste lecaplain c'était
trop bien et déjà été super cool avec
nous
on l'avait jamais rencontré et il était
super abordable est trop sympa trop
content d'être là pour le coup c'était
un des rares guest cinoche qu'on est
dans notre film s'est confié parce qu'en
fait il là cheveux car en fait c'est la
possession c'est ça se fait dans le
visage et du cou tuvalu faire juste des
jours comme ça il qu'un habitant
derrière et c'est toi bâtisse qui donne
le mouvement tu donnes la violence du
truc en mettant sa tête en arrière
tiens pourquoi c'est qu'on retient c'est
pas lui qui forge et moi c'était le
dernier plan la tulipe en jour là je
suis plus faire la vistule
[Musique]
salut bonjour bienvenue sur le plateau
de tournage du prochain suricates
catherine deneuve qui a laissé son odeur
son odeur corporelle sur chacun de ses
meubles
ce meuble en bois par exemple mais bois
une limitation marbre hallucinante et ce
magnifique portrait de giscard d'estaing
hyper mal représentés je tourne sur un
club où ça va les transports sont
difficiles attendent et assure la
première semaine en anglais tous
ensemble la de couper le soir là dans un
magnifique décor mais bizarrement il est
plus il est plus beau que quadrillait
médias improvisation on y tourner la
scène du trader qui est une scène
importante du scénario parce que c'est
le moment où l'héroïne donc lily 20 pour
tous quitté tout lâcher à l'écrit on l'a
appelé le trader et on s'est dit il nous
faut du lourd
il faut un mec qui envoie un petit peu
du charisme donc on a fait appel à
slimane bâtisse beroun le talentueux
le virtuose le funambule en fait j'ai
pas lu exprès le scénar j'ai vu juste
raf m'a dit étage c'est 60 65
t'es pas obligé de dire le reste si tu
veux garder la surprise effectivement
non seulement je m'en fous mais en plus
après que ça je suis d'accord ou
qu'est-ce que je fais là au départ dans
le texte c'était écrit quand même
séquence assez vaste ans on voulait en
effet que ce soit un premier en tout cas
d'un peu d'action et un premier échange
de coups et c'est le lieu tellement beau
et tellement fragile qu'on va éviter de
faire trop de trucs trop bourrin tout ce
qu'on doit comprendre c'est que que je
m'enfuis et je sèche slim
ea comme ça les fait ça et je tombe sur
la classe à lui une marge totale soir
pour moi je vais faire ça j'ai un statut
des tournées joie jeu là que je sais que
tu as soir
et c'était justement tu fonces vers moi
juste la chaise comme comme obstacle
j'essaye vraiment de me toucher
ça peut le faire vous voir investisseurs
[Musique]
je pense que là on va vraiment faire du
thabor ça va mais je pense faut que tu
amorphe le mouvement pour que soit tu me
suis tu vois j'ai peur croisé fouetter
le dos et puis qui se prend que si le
fauteuil en plein travail cinq fois et
on s'en fout faut que je sois crédit
était question de tablettes dans la
gueule était question de sauter sur un
bureau tour créé sur le mois à travers
et c'est dernier plan d'eau ce qui m'a
mené 6-0
on a des grands de demain qui nous donne
aux autres de nous lâcher 24h 24h voilà
qui sont d'accord qu'on a repéré ya
trois semaines on a fait des coupes
agents de fonction voilà on craque ne
manqueront pas encore des corps qui nous
a lâchés pour le lendemain au genou l'a
caché au début et nous l'a avoué un peu
plus tard dans la journée
on n'avait pas de décor pour lendemain
mais c'est tout le talent du lycée kanu
l'a annoncé avec des solutions déjà
du coup la veille on a dû trouver en
vous
est-ce qu'on tourne ça et c'est eléonore
cost qui a dirigé la partie se
débrouiller donc là on essaie de
mordelles la parte et pour que ce soit
l'appartement de milo et versa sur une
bidouille le mettre en cache et un an
après l'entrée de lumière enfin tu
litigieux parce que toi et dehors on n'a
pas de show contrairement à voir comme
ça plein mais il ya beaucoup hier
c'était vraiment la merde et il ya
beaucoup de gens qui passent et qui
rigolent et des voitures
le calme on a aujourd'hui toutes parts
camille cas de saignement bas faire des
travaux qu'on n'a pas encore vu
au milieu il recule on a calé mais les
éboueurs sur ouais c'est pas pour tout
de suite
ils vont faire un nom dans l'agglo un
petit tout un petit trajet d'une heure
bon pour toi a chjama action quant à 1
propose un truc qui vous avec ses mains
pour quand il manipule et les gens et ça
rendait super bien ce graphiquement
c'était super roo j'avais vraiment
l'impression de tourner un manga
français
vu que c'est un duo
il y avait beaucoup de trucs à prévoir
ensemble et c'est ça ils l'ont fait par
le tournage s'est-elle trois guerres
c'est ça le voisin du dessus ça c'est 2
1 c'est pas nous la journée sur le toit
on l'a préparé la veille juste après le
tournage chez vidéo on a comme ça à
orchestrer les petite baston avec trois
vrilles et plus elle est là dans un
resto il fait bon voilà ce que je vois
je vais simplifiée plein de choses et à
la fois comme ça on aura peut-être plus
de temps pour tourner avoir de l'émotion
sur sur la mort de magali que je remette
dedans d'un coup la retrouver les
personnages c'est bête mais on avait à
peu près trouvé nos personnages
dernières semaines donc il a fallu faire
choper on avait sept ports la con de pas
retrouvé les persos surtout vincent avec
magali qu'un personnage assez précis
mais sur le toit du grand rex pour la
bataille finale donc c'est le moment
milo s'est réfugié sur le toit de la
boîte de nuit et magali arrivée essaye
de l'arrêter sauf qu'elles subissent et
possédé par milan n'a 41 flanc à faire
entrer trois quarts de journée voilà
comme ça est très sport se faire battre
par le soleil d'hiver que le temps sera
avec nous et qui on va crever d'une
insolation
je donne une insolation sur un tournage
sur la toile on n'essayait pas trop
bronzé parce qu'il restait du tournage
après donc on voulait pas se taper un le
teint de bernard montiel
on était venu ici tourner super aux
hangover la fin de ce personnage je te
suis là et alors ce désir de revenir je
sais mais c'est la dernière fois promis
oui je sais que l'état des lieux c'est
demain je sais mais là je suis à
l'étranger en fait encore une fois je
suis désolé bienvenue à la poste
oui mais ce dakar mais que c'était un
plan stylet mais c'est vrai que c'est
très court est attendu à ce que ce
résultat
quand on veut pas faire une grosse scène
d'action et on l'a fait c'est ce que
j'ai moins envie de mettre ça sur
environ 20 secondes là dedans en 20
secondes ce que c'est c'est bon ça fait
vingt secondes savais pas du tout
comment on allait tourner ces cantons de
pouma dans le money et on tournait ce
qui se passait après derrière donc fait
le combat
en fait on fait vraiment comme ça et
d'un coup de jet je pense que ça va être
trois dans l'accès aux salles bien mais
je me suis régionales mais j'aurais pu
plus brillé en fait là j'ai vraiment
sauté ville et roger les mecs fécales
sûr quand on le touche
sur sa lancée l'énergie va être content
j'ai peur qu'on écrivait un truc un peu
fantastique un peu de buzz nc mois soit
pas critique en fait tout se passe à
l'intérieur le week-end les efficient
on n'avait pas beaucoup ce matin l'agent
n'est pas chanteur pendant talent unique
et ses cordes vocales
voilà fin de carrière mais c'est marrant
de méchant génial parce que tu penses
que tu veux tu peux tu es le droit
d'être bizarre ça c'est vraiment génial
pour un lecteur de faire ce que tu veux
c'est venu comme ça pendant les essais
et après il m'a dit ouais c'est bien
c'est intéressant fouilles cherche un
peu joker la crise nous sommes capables
de saigner autant c'est noir et c'est du
béton
c'est dégoûtant
du coup c'est chaud c'est quand on a
écrit c'était pas l'été alors s'est dit
qu'on mettrait des shows varetz écrire
des trucs en slip prochaine fois on
écrit les mecs en slip sens que si on
écrit en était fort mais des mecs en
slip en hiver les risques du métier
et comme une merde
sur la clavicule c'est le soleil attaque
sévère le stress aussi parce que ou plan
aujourd'hui et les ménines stress la
scène de la mort de magali c'était une
scène qui faisait plus peur du film est
à la fois que j'avais très envie de voir
et à fois que j'avais très bien calé
dans ma tête j'ai demande à julie
contournant en petit comité on était
vraiment que le cadreur afin de rémy
clément et nous et j'ai même demandé à
julie et de toute l'équipe d'être cachés
plus loin pour concentrer entre nous
et du coup ça fait partie de mes
souvenirs les plus forts mais les plus
durs aussi en même temps fin mélange de
tout parce que c'était dur parce qu on
galérait à faire ressortir cette émotion
on voulait que ça soit crédible
c'est un peu l'apogée et l'apothéose de
notre projet on savait assez vite que la
résolution de leurs soucis se passerait
probablement par une fusion de leurs
deux esprits lors de zam dans un seul et
même corps et là c'est le moment où l'on
appelle un one shot ou en faire certes
mais ton budget et spéciaux là dedans
pour que ce soit beau et enfin voir le
côté vraiment sf2 on voit les âmes
clairement un nul et on les voit
fusionner l'une et l'autre donc là on va
faire le plan sur la fusion des âmes le
fera en leader je pense aux friches et
on l'âme se fusionnent on les voit
fusionner ce torsadé sait pas encore
mais déjà la set facile et on l'a
vraiment expédié cette partie
trente deux projets conséquents on n'a
pas le temps de favori en fait cette
semaine m'a paru plus long parce que
chaque jour on changer de décor et
d'univers alors que le deux semaines ont
tourné toute sorte de global ou dans
l'appart etc
et du coup ça passe
vite
juste rendu compte au maire d'amou déjà
jeudi et c'est avec la star l'essai n'a
pas tourné cette semaine était vraiment
cool
et puis finir la semaine sur ce à quoi
on tourne ici on a trop de la chance ma
vie on est dans une belle ville et à une
prochaine
bobby ray ce nom alors tout se passe
bien une boîte de nuit quatre nuits 4
lui quatre jours tourne arédien aussi un
autre rythme discontinue aussi mais qu'a
pu dans le même lieu donc à mon avis
c'est une synthèse de des deux semaines
contre la faim
première semaine tu t'en sors à peu près
tu tire sur la corde deuxième semaine tu
tire sur la corde troisième semaine
était en bout de course quoi on savait
qu'on serait fatigué en fait on le
savait ange est juste on savait pas à
quel moment on serait très fatigué c'est
le début de la troisième semaine on
pourrait dire que c'est la fin pour
première nuit à la discothèque savez ce
sympathique
on va faire du 20h à 8h environ je vous
donne des des fourchettes pour avoir ces
prises avec un peu dur je pense qu'en
tout le monde et après
et trois nuit d'après semences oeuvres
ou les courses un cas d'école je suis le
frère de carlito il vient de te voir
pour la première fois ça fait dix ans
c'est pas banal pas si elle pas mais bon
j'avouerai comme je disais tout à
l'heure un raphaël que je sais pas
encore exactement lesquels de mes
répliques jeudi ans serge et les caisses
zip en l'état parce que comme sur le
scénario
les soviets rapacité des fois que
c'était l'ère qu'il y avait des mais
quand il est arrivé sur le tournage
c'est ce qui m'a dit venez de lire le
script il m'a dit [__] j'ai adoré pas
tout pigé mais j'adorais avant je suis
ta gueule resté stoïque avec ce qu'il a
l'habitude d'aller cet avocat extérieur
et demie du matin à s'améliorer
c'est le début qui a tué retard
auxquelles à tourner et actions j'ai un
mélange des phrases bien je vous êtes
malade et the times mardi
[Applaudissements]
salut bonjour
willy turquoise et moi ya carrément il
nous reste trois jours deux temps trois
nuits tournage julie coudry arrivée un
peu en bout de course elle a enquillé
avec des sketches l'ape du golden
moustache des sketches youtube du golden
moustache et elle a enchaîné direct avec
ce projet le projet chantal ses massifs
chez manager c'est juste mon corps qui
me traitent cette pochette les gens
commençaient sur ce film c'est
uniquement des gens qui avaient la
motivation extrême en fait preuve de ce
que c'est en effet si on a fait un film
aux conditions extrêmes en fait c'est un
peu ce à quoi tient la corde
je t'encule shining version junior merci
enfants pas sûr de ce que ça rentre
on verra on peut se balader dans ce
grand départ pour faire genre ici te
rattrape
tu prends peur c'est gentil ça le
bouteille je suis en train de diviser
une bouteille en sucre injustice
soucasse immédiatement s'il fait un bon
match je pense que je suis la prochaine
évolution de l'humanité
on va tous être comme ça j'ai plus ou
moins humain est certain d'être lé gard
servant de la première action il se
dispute en europe et après demain tard
quand on est en haut des escaliers mais
ça tourne moins on sait action
[Musique]
top
il faut bien voir mais je vais y
réfléchir
maintenant si vous êtes soit tu n'as
aucune idée sur votre excellence et du
savoir
[Applaudissements]
ok couper une grosse prise de risques
parce que on a fait des très beaux plans
mais à la fois j'ai aucune marche de
montage
enfin j'ai pas grand chose en phase de
montage alors que d'habitude j'ai plus
l'habitude de faire des larges et plein
de séries pour pouvoir bien monté
choisir toutes les prises et c'est là je
suis assez restreint mais on a tellement
des comédiens de ouf et des techniciens
de ouf que je suis conscient très
confiant on tourne le dernier plan du
film juste avant sa phase cote noir
générique je suis adapté chez magali et
tu viens placé entre d'accord stasi tard
et on jouera tous alors aujourd'hui on a
des cours vous ne devrez pas vous
expliquer bien ça semble évident
comprendre on va s'échauffer
jalila on s'ouvre donc voilà attention
on va jouer à chaque fois rejetées
capuche vraiment il landes ont envie de
vomir était pas bien et et il y avait
beaucoup de doutes et où est-ce qu'ils
vont enfin comme nous tout en vieux
renard pour être plus simple jus ce
qu'on fasse pas de light et qu'on fasse
une mise en place comédiens clair pour
tout le monde
ça pourra rouler deux heures et demie
comme ça à cette heure on a fixé une kia
souvent 6 en calant deux nations sont en
mode automatique ou on exécute et doit
faire confiance à ce qu'on a écrit parce
qu'on a pu le temps d'y réfléchir et
donc il faut qu'on exécute ce qui en a
fait un séquencier déjà et en temps il
faut qu'on s'y tiennent en revanche il
ya des séquences qui sont exportés sont
simplifiées ont fait moins de plans et
on va à l'essentiel plus de quoi on ne
sont pas les représentent
je pensais pas que ce serait moi
ces dépenses extra qui sait quelqu'un
d'autre est fatigué avoue aussi ne
faiblira moi j'étais à prêt à beaucoup
de retard on a surtout perdu directrice
de brot-dessous
m
donc voilà on va aller je suis proposé
on va essayer de reprendre tout son
travail sans esbroufe en train de perdre
des membres de l'équipe s'est appuyé ses
copains c'est dur de rester efficace
quant à lui équipé ceux qui croient
qu'on regarderait sage vous pris dix
premiers en compte toutes les séquences
que vous verrez dans cette [__] de
mode ont été tournées dans des
conditions extrêmes les fait que les
deux premières nuits soient passés ça
m'enlève médias c'est fait donc la
montagne est moins haute
et puis je me dire si on fait ça on fait
ça quand même pour s'amuser c'est pour
s'amuser et c'est pour amuser les autres
donc au final si c'est un parfait grave
c'est juste que je me mettais une
pression très forte de on doit être
parfait et touré c'est un parfait c'est
pas grave
la seule envie de tout ce combat c'est
quoi c'est que julien dépossède terry et
s'excuse après
[Musique]
le carlito prennent de pain dans la
gueule anin pas en plus quoi donc ce qui
peut arriver c'est que quand on descend
là ils sont tous face à nous ce qui se
passe ça qui était dans la troisième
partie
on avait besoin que ben c'est mon site
un peu s'épanouissent et soir un peu lui
qui sache aussi aller à l'affront et
qu'ils aillent au conflit que qu'ils
aillent se battre et finalement du coup
à la base c'est emilie qui devait faire
et finalement on a fait ben vu que je
lis un vincent et moi on est réalisateur
scénariste des communes un truc on peut
réécrire notre film sur place
en effet dans tout le troisième acte on
n'a pas de mini évolution soit l'attend
chaque truc elle faire un truc héroïque
coeur gpat monde
je pense être réparé du coup on avance
un peu sur le moment où vient de changer
au dernier moment de mise en place des
bus est véridique il devait faire cette
action
finalement c'est bête et là il ya une
demi heure trois quart d'heure on se dit
on il faut décider ça timing assez
précise de me lancer pour mon âme sort
de cette mystique atterri le deuil
j'appelle délit joseph
je me lance merci des scénaristes y en
avait eu doit pas mal dans des films
avec bruce willis et tous les scènes de
baston là c'est exactement pareil mais
un peu au dessus de bousculer si tu
avais demandé dans le scénario suppose
que c'est le moment de faire les choses
soient nos logiques ce que tu fais ça tu
peux faire et karachi
mais ça je savais pas ce que j'allais
faire un piège de l'estac va j étais pas
mais j'avais matin dans le dvd du making
of et comme on n'avait pas de cascadeur
c'était aussi sympa de prendre du temps
comme ça sont des chorégraphies à
l'avancé avec la caméra tu deviens belle
et d'ailleurs ils m'appellent je peux
tourner la tête par magali vous paye pas
ses propositions et remet pas et passe
ainsi si vous arrivez là vous avez fait
une s c'est extrêmement complexe il faut
l'avoir fait
ok et appelle des cracks il a une pige
pour six métiers différents sur ceux sur
cette famille
très belle fête non
un petit plan séquence ou bien caler les
positions parce que de se battre
raf avec un service tic on lui a jetée
et
oui police vers gens là ils ont donné un
coup à la caméra et surtout gens qui
doit taper dans l'assassinât mais n'a
jamais avant dans les d'autres prisons
l'a fait ça à fond tu vois il ya ça
aussi
oui parce que c'était là moeurs
l'argentine on nous envoie un texto ils
nous demandent des conseils maintenant
des cracks appels et les pc des
manquements et des boues sont partis un
peu sur les membres du ca va tout le
monde va bien
[Musique]
merci m stéphane carlo qui s'occupe des
pêcheurs où travaillent avec lui depuis
la saison une sur les quatre et même
mois bien avant puisque on est potes de
collège ou à des vidéos dans notre
jardin en jambes et donc du coup il
c'est lui qui fait la plupart des effets
spéciaux depuis les buts suricates
on a toujours dialoguer avec lui comment
toi tu verrais les âmes
qu'est ce que ça représente quoi quelle
forme ça ce que ça t'as fumé est ce que
c'est
imaginez un peu de boules déjà et donc
du coup il ya toujours on a toujours
beaucoup débattu avec lui sur à quoi ça
pourrait ressembler comment ça pourrait
fonctionner comment on s'envoie les a
mais parce qu'il n'y a pas de mots c'est
pas des captures d'écran on a du mal pas
de talent mais qui ose même temps un bon
herpès plus la beauté repasse de trois
semaines tu l'a inscrit sur youtube avis
c'est terminé on n'a pas de maquiller
leurs noms aient paniqué je suis moche
que j'arrive sur un pull sans fred de
cette nuit
l'impression qu'ils sont quand même
assez cramer oui je joue nous absolument
j'échange je me dis ceci n'est qu'une
mouche plus passer par le regard et le
sens peut-être les pattes comme ça que
ça fasse trop animal c'est dans la mine
insectes jour là vraiment avec un public
des trucs de rendre fallout 2 oui il
faut pas laisser cette mouche sur la
nature et le van dyk a rentré dedans et
à sang la bd par delà le matelas de
conneries du génie c'était le dernier
plan de william pelletier
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
aussi le dernier plan de thomas levet
[Applaudissements]
c'est génial c'est quand même pas
beaucoup de familles à tous les ans on
verra pas me gâter par accor mec je te
suffit je pense qu'ils étape je me
changeais hockey et actions j'étais déjà
venu chez moi j'avance tout doucement en
avance tout doucement et actions dernier
plan de pantin et de crever nova
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
sur toute l'année la semaine on a
accumulé un retard est en effet des
séquences qu'on décalé de jour en jour
c'était pour julie qui organisait le
tournage constante remise en question de
ce qu'on tourne aujourd'hui qu'est-ce
qu'on tombera le premier qui n'aura su
dès hier à pour une séquence sur
laquelle on aurait eu besoin de 2 à 2,2
eur il ne reste pas de trois minutes à
ce qui implique on va grossir les gens
qui demain on n'a pas pu faire rentrer
le combat entre marsu martiaux ni et
julien et moi ont ils été prévu et vous
demandons c'est parce qu'il ya cette
heure on fait bien être encore ça a
tourné
comment ai je vois julien qui vient me
voir en me disant ok ok n'aura plus le
temps de cette séquence je les faire des
chichis recoins où il allait réfléchir
avec julie et où il est revenu en disant
ok ce que je propose c'est que là on
finit toi cette salle on répète avec
martiaux yoni un combat important
peut-être huit ans nathan de calais le
combat a tourné le choix il nous paraît
tel est le combat on répète comédien est
aimé et les limites à 80 ans il était
pas plus tôt devant des feux juste
demander si demain pour avoir exactement
sur ça on n'est pas né dans l'après
battue et visage à bhl aussi jolie de
faty facteurs étaient en train de
préparer une corée avec julien on l'a
montré à yoni m'a reçue ensuite ils ont
développé avec raph et ils ont vraiment
quelle est sa au mieux sa langue au
quotidien ces genres on est un peu en
stand by comme ça tu vois un petit
moment il ya des trucs toute attaque et
esquive intrus qui ont peur
non et c'est sur ces mouvements qui
attaquent on va pour y aller on va pour
y aller tu vois j'ai fait on n'ose pas
on fait supporter monde n'ose pas trop
au début tu aurais chose tu vois ça
c'est toi vas y aurait le calage et
sharp ont déjà tenté un coup de poing
l'acl khattak
ouais tu m'as bien que j'attaque je l'
esquive j'ai du coup je te rattrape avec
richard l'avouerez ouais tu là tous les
châteaux les attaques directes étaient
déjà dans le truc plus ou moins en même
temps yayo nikki qui il arriva le
chopper loin du coup je me lève je rende
parachute a viré de mon truc dans
l'idéal serait cool de que ça reste pas
trop en odeur on est vachement près
ouais oui pour moi c'est tout l'espace
en fait tu les vois pas partir du moment
où on y vas tu as ces jarres hockey et
nous du coup nous nous on peut prendre
tout ça et vous vous avez tout ça quoi
et nous mêmes on a ça je suis pas sûr
qu'on aurait réussi à la rentrée et si
on l'avait fait leur a sûrement été mal
fait et là le fait de la faire le
lendemain vu qu'on avait les comédiens
qui était prévu de toute façon lendemain
on l'a fait plus vite et moins stressé
parce que plus problème de problèmes de
l'horloge qui tourne
c'est la dernière minute donc là je suis
mitigé entre entre un peu la déprime
parce que c'est la fin du tournage mais
d'un autre côté je suis contente
de savoir que pendant quelques heures
douzaine d'heures je vais voir me
coucher et dormir pendant 72 heures
d'affilée melman une maintenance ou
serrer les coudes en ont tous appris sur
nous et sur les autres
austin valence il perd enrichissante est
surtout connue
[Musique]
je suis content qu'on arrive à la fin du
tournage ça veut dire qu'on a réussi
mais là tout reste encore à faire parce
que mine de rien en fait on a une
séquence de retard par rapport à hier
il va y avoir une nostalgie je pense ce
week-end on va tous être un peu triste
pour l'internal mais la fois content que
tout soit rentré mais je ne peux pas du
tout te dire ce que je ressens tire
quand on finira parce que là je suis
encore de compresser en moi la chute
attendue de dahra les tiens encore à
quelques heures de l'énergie on donne
tout encore prendre quelques heures sur
deux jours on a eu l'idée film est le
premier en tournage et moins de trois
mois donc c'est chauffe
le truc c'est que là on est déjà en
train de réaliser mais très bon on est
déjà en train de faire ce qu'on voulait
faire depuis tout môme se fait en son
temps et on sait déjà forte que 3 de
faire on élargit aussi toute la petite
souris sont là
puis trois semaines ou tard et est donc
simple plaisir de sentir un peu seul à
vouloir faire des projets ça la pâte on
voit que c'est assez plate comme un
miroir en fait ces deux gamines à fait
simple quoi ça sent le regard c'est
julien doré dans le même temps tousart
[Musique]
j'ai un peu on dirait que tu es roncq
cela me dépasse elle a choqué les a dits
nickel oh le joli coup ça c'est une des
preuves qu'on a écrit très rapidement
parce qu'ils n'étaient pas dire ça dans
un film tu le sors tu dire nickel le
joli coup si j'avais une monte jusqu'à
une version très tardive du montage
oh le joli coup c'était de rester dans
le montage tuyaux c'était le dernier
plan d'eléonore cost
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les derniers plans de sabine perron ces
dernières sont beaucoup de gens c'est
bientôt le dernier plan de nous mêmes
ces derniers pointent chinois alors non
je vais déjà transféré mais non
éclaircies jeu sinon on fait ce genre
tous les dialogues en mode statique
en effet on les enregistre après je veux
dire tous les achats à aller ça va
coller ça va proposer quand même on a
répété le combat pour qu'aujourd'hui on
ne soit plus efficace salue faire mais
on fait le combat du coup avant le avant
la scène du bar ouais on sait qu'il ya
beaucoup d'action ça a été à peu près
des coupés mais en gros je vais quand
même essayer de les suivre en faisant
plusieurs valeurs et après on va
resserrer plus en plus en fait on fait
très largement fait encore un truc un
peu plus large sur l'action d'un côté et
après on va faire des pick up des
moments et le mépris du moment essentiel
qu'il faut avoir pour la compréhension
de la scène et le district law le même
du pouce t-shirt ou 10 restants jean
bestiaux naître
tandis que jean-paul canaud cadeau et on
fait des corrections et tuent par son
côté un peu pesante ont pas l'un sur
l'autre
jeudi on essaye vraiment là bien ok bah
du coup ça va être ça les ovaires
j'essaie de le dire ici up pas les
ovaires on sait jamais si jamais on a
des gosses je pense aussi aux plate et
tu descends du coup comme ça pour avouer
c'est à toi de correct était maintenant
quand même je pense
ouais ne prend pas drogué alors ça
j'entame va la rejeter à l'envoyer avec
la tête tu sais que tu sais qui a
toujours fait en dehors tu récupères
temaru et je te prends pas la tête
ce qu'il faut c'est que kraft très
stoïque
il reste pro julien a le recul et
rencontre qui va rouler une pelle à son
pote des derniers plans de marsu est
unique
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ce dernier blanc cette dernière séquence
j'ai barré tout scénario tout sauf
j'attends plus qui sait combien je suis
pas très content c'est à dire c'est fini
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pardon
[Musique]
à la fois on est fiers de finir à la fin
on est triste parce que c'était quand
même une belle épopée quoi on était
content d'avoir réussi à rentrer ce
grand projet quoi ces 90 pages qu'on
avait fini de rédiger seulement trois
semaines avant et mu est fatigué de
d'avoir fini et d'avoir fini avec tous
ces gens là que j'adore je m'attendais à
ce qu'on l'a a également libéré affaire
raymond on a réussi notre mission
maintenant on va y dormir et j'ai eu la
boule qui reste est refaite et donc du
coup je me suis rendu compte qu'en fait
j'avais regardé avoir pour plusieurs
mois pour la post prod pour tout et tu
restes nous et tant que banque a pas des
gens et qu'ils t'en dis c'est bien on
est content ça nous a plu ça nous a fait
rire même un peu tueur le montage
c'était cool au début quand je devais
monter chaque scène isolée c'était
intéressant j'aimais bien ce que je
voyais il ya des hauts et des bas mais
globalement j'étais super content après
il faut tout mettre bout à bout et tu
découvres ce que tu as fait et graff
avait fait tout le taf de tout mon
talent dont il était 1h30 les leaders au
35mm froid de films et donc on a regardé
tous les 3es avec une admission de
directeur artistique
on est très content parce qu'on voit que
ça tire c'est vraiment tellement
conforme au scénario qu'on a écrit que
ce qui marche marche nous rassure et
c'est une marche et pas dans le scénar
ça se voit ça marche pas du tout
et donc on est on est inquiet qu'on
apprend on aime ou on a fait d avoir
deux scénarios en fait dedans donc on a
dû les réparer après au montage on se
disait on se rattrapera on sait qu'on se
rattrape en on sait pas comment au
tournage ou en post prod est donc là en
voyant la projo c'est fait elle s'est
cependant pas de preuves je savais que
le personnage de lily fonctionnait pas
dans le film il avait un problème il les
gens ne comprenaient pas son choix
donc quand on a fait la projo tess les
gens nous ont confirmé ça quand lily
décide de tout quitter partir on va chez
le trader comprenez pas ses motivations
et donc du coup on n'était pas avec elle
on la perd des équipes en ce moment là
les coudes face en train de violer c'est
le personnage principal et c'est un lieu
parce que ça ça pose toute une partie de
l' émotion car acquis qu'il pouvait y
avoir un film témoin d'alain le
personnage du goûter même parfois
retrait tu dis mais il n'aime pas trop
ce personnage comprends pas tu comprends
pas tu l'identifient pas de la paille
était un peu en dehors du film donc on
s'est dit qu'avec seulement un plan ou
deux de rafah en train de quitter le
lieu ça pouvait suffire pour montrer sa
et le raf aussi dans les marches en
train de
lire le protocole d dissocier et de se
rendre compte un peu de sa condition et
de sa place dans la société en tout cas
vu par les dissocier et il ya vraiment
une étape de réécriture qui fait au
montage que moi j'avais peut-être un peu
sous-estimé en tout cas je pensais qu'il
y aurait une mais peut-être pas aussi
lourdes c'est la séquence où carlito
nous parle des 10 au ciel
c'est un gros bout d'exposition te
bouffe que de l'info pendant cinq
minutes autour d'un bar les plans de jeu
pas beaucoup de questions qui se
posaient autour de magali pourquoi la
cette tronche doit bien qu'ils aient mis
l'eau qu'est ce qu'il a vraiment fait
donc on a fait une séquence animée
on s'est dit que c'était peut-être un
peu audacieux et que ça pouvait marcher
se dit c'est cool mais il faudra un bon
dessinateur et wladimir qui a proposé
boulet je fais mais jamais on n'aura
boulet à atteindre à des conneries
jamais dispo d'où il voudra faire ça et
le mec vous a dit écoutez je suis dispo
en plus je suis tentée j'aime bien
donc ok on est chaud il est super rapide
super efficace talent ce milo est devenu
très dangereux
c'est lui qui détient encore le montage
certainement découragement puis tu
rebondis ta l'idée c'est d'y arriver là
là je sais pas ce qu'il va y arriver
parce que il ya plus de temps et appeler
les moyens aériens la fatigue et puis
finalement on est elle toujours et que
le compositeur julien bélanger ont gelé
tenu au courant très tôt pendant qu'on
écrivait le film que l'on avait besoin
de lui et qu'on aimerait qu'il fasse la
bo du film et du coup il a dès qu'on lui
envoyait des bouts de scénario ou même
les scénarios entier et commence à
composer des trucs et ce mec est fou
c'est là le talent là elles un talent
monstre gilles bélanger et une
efficacité de travail de dingue 3 vient
d'être avec lui parce que tu donnes un
truc et le direct du pain une fois qu'on
a verrouillé le montage donc on s'est
dit qu'on n'y touche plus c'est ça notre
histoire
tant pis si elle ce qui marche pas et il
ya plein de trucs qui marchent donc
faisons confiance
on a envoyé le montage a du coup à la le
mixage l'autre s'occupe du son et et à
l'étalonnage qui va s'occuper de l'image
ça c'était notre image de base avec on
trace et rad est saturé pour garder
plein de détails et apprête à la chasse
d'habitude on vous l étalonnage nous
larache pendant le montage tu vois et là
on s'est dit qu'on allait prendre une
telle odeur dont il est question dans
ces métiers en contact avec florian et
qu'elle était vraiment il a transformé
les images qu'il ya des plans les arrow
découvert parce qu'on les a bouffés
pendant des mois et des mois pendant le
montage sans un talonnage et là il
refoule une couche de couleur de macha
il corrige les imperfections et
et donc le web l'image vraiment on prend
une deuxième vie en termes de sont à des
sons qui font boum stades et des bons
bruitages qui sont vite à la musique et
au bon endroit et hassar a ajouté une
bouffée d'air frais en fait tu re
découvre ton film tu t'appelles magali
métaphore
[Musique]
et où la grosse
[Applaudissements]
ce film représente vraiment tout le
parcours qu'on a eue toute l'évolution
qu'on a eu c'est vrai que dans ma tête
je ne vois vraiment comme un season
finale un peu suricates même si j'espère
qu'on fera d'autres choses carnoux 3
avait écrit un long métrage jamais pour
tout le monde c'est la première fois
hélas pas un os et jardins moi j'avais
déjà fait un méga et google agen donc ya
pas deux il n'y a pas de regrets on
découvre tous c'est vraiment un choix
d'avoir bossé ensemble pour faire ce
type de projet
j'aurais pu faire avec personne d'autre
parce qu'on se connaît vraiment bien tu
es obligé de travailler avec des gens
avec qui tu ris en fait tous les jours
parce que c'est c'est générer durée
c'est de faire rire d'autres genres donc
si tu étais pas rire mutuellement ça
marche pas tu vois on est tous les trois
aussi fou mais fou dans ce sens faut
lire vraiment dans le sens malade et
l'avoir fait avec eux c'est le meilleur
endroit possible
c'est le résultat qu'on espérait au
moment où on s'est lancés en fait enfin
c'est fait c'est
l'affect même si personne l'aisne ce
film sera pas été vains tu vois ce qu'on
aura appris énormément de choses dans
avec une belle aventure récents ratés
serait maintenant c'est fini
donc tout de suite envie d'en faire un
nouveau développé un autre projet
janvier d'affaires de avec aucune ride
un sens avec l'étonnant on voulait
prouver que c'était possible d'écrire un
film relate à faire donc en fait avant
fin mai
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
joli cadeau